The gods gave us many gifts,
one day you'll know them all
This is where we keep them
It's beautiful
Who would weild it?
Only the fiercest among us even could, and that is not you Diana
You will train her harder, than any amazon before her
5 times harder
10 times harder
Never let your guard down. You expect the battle to be fair?
Until she is better than even you!
But she must never know the truth about what she is...
"What is this place? Who are you?"
It is our sacred duty to defend the world
Right.
Whoever you are, you are in more danger than you think
Be careful Diana
If no one else will defend the world, then I must
Welcome to jolly ol' London!
It's hideous
Yeah it's not for everybody
Stand back
Or maybe not...
is there anything else you wanna show me?
What are you?
I am Diana of Themyscira, daughter of [Queen] Hippolyta
In the name of all that is good, till wrath upon this world is over
Oh
yep... that's not going to work
please put the sword down
it doesn't go with the outfit, at all...